all right let's talk about another movie
where the ladies are large and in charge
a league of their own is celebrating its
25th anniversary this year and ET was
there back in the day with the all-star
cast on the set were we heard for the
very first time one of the most
unforgettable lines in movie history
crying there's no crying in baseball
so we know there's no crying in baseball
but here are some things you may not
know about the film it was Tom Hanks and
director penny Marshall's second
collaboration after their mega hit big
four years earlier
oh the gem manager oh yeah big lush Tom
played Jimmy Dugan an ex baseball player
turned all-american girls baseball
league manager with a drinking problem
he gained 30 pounds for the role with
the help of a Dairy Queen near the rural
Indiana set I had to get fat I had to I
had to gain some weight so I had to eat
barbecue pork ribs and enjoy enjoy the
deserts of America so to speak but at
the time all the buzz was about
Madonna's performance oops my bosoms
come flying on them dead then my my draw
crowd right dick there were men in this
country you ain't seen your bosoms she
has a great appetite for x-men life she
captivated the press but struggled so
badly fielding ground balls her
character's position was moved from
third base to outfield
unfortunately not Madonna made fast
friends with newcomer Rosie O'Donnell
it's a friendship that endures today
goes 106° hundred twenty on the field a
lot of people passed out yeah a lot of
puking yeah lot of sweating what are you
looking at yeah what are you looking at
a league of their own was Rosie's
breakout role but she confessed not
everything was rosy with the cast on set
well here's the Hollywood version
everyone loved each other and it was a
great thing but you know there were
little cliques that formed and reformed
and people were friends and then not
friends and we all sort of reverted to
our adolescence for part of the filming
at the LA premiere Geena Davis warned
Nicole Miller gown with some familiar
stitching well it's a baseball as you
can see I thought it maybe went with a
theme Tom brought wife Rita married just
four years at the time he dug out every
single Sports cliche he could muster my
players all gave 110% and I think I
think at the end of it you only got to
take you every game one game at a time
but I think the final analysis is not
over till the fat lady sings I cannot
get enough of Tom Hanks in this role one
more fact to throw out there Geena Davis
was actually the last person cast do me
Moore was the frontrunner for the lead
role but she was pregnant with her
daughter scouts so she missed out and
Debra Winger backed out at the last
minute by the way the 25th anniversary
DVD of the movie was just released today
you